bonjour et merci d'être avec nous en
direct alors les négociations bien le
dire hors kitchen pourquoi lorsque les
deux côtés sont trop séparés l'un de
l'autre
vous l'avez dit dans le reportage vous
l'avez entendu l'union européenne veut
que le royaume uni continuent à obéir
aux règles et à respecter les normes
européennes et londres dit très
exactement le contraire londres dit il
n'est pas question de rester alignés sur
les normes européennes
nos propres normes visent les
britanniques seront peut-être plus
strictes ou moins strictes mais
l'essentiel c'est que les normes ne sont
pas alignés parce que cela serait
incompatible avec la l'indépendance
nationale et les deux côtés ne se
comprennent plus et puis ensuite il ya
la question de la pêche qui est une
question beaucoup plus concrets étaient
beaucoup plus banal les eaux
territoriales britanniques qui sont très
grandes le royaume uni la grande
bretagne étant comme tout le monde c'est
une île et un pendant 40 ans eh bien les
pêcheurs français espagnols et autres
ont pu pêcher sans aucune limite dans
les eaux territoriales territoriales
britanniques 1 depuis l'adhésion du
royaume uni et bien toute une industrie
en france en espagne et ailleurs dépens
de cela et de cet accès alors là aussi
le royaume uni dixon il est pas question
que cela continue comme avant
puisque justement ainsi le royaume uni
n'est plus membre de l'union européenne
et bien comment pourrait-on envisager
d'avoir une politique commune de la
pêche qui continueraient donc voilà
alors est ce que ce sont des postures
est ce que ce sont des prises de
position publiques afin de renvoyer
l'échec s'il y en a un sur le dos de
l'autre c'est possible je n'ai pas de
jeu je ne suis pas que les royaux je ne
sais pas ce qui va se passer mais il est
vrai que je suis étonné de voir comment
bruxelles adopte ce que londres à mon
sens a raison d'appeler une position
idéologique parce que cette histoire
d'alignement sur les normes
bruxelles ne l'a jamais demandé à aucun
autre pays bruxelles n'a pas demandé au
canada ou à eux mêmes pas des pays du
tiers monde comme le vietnam avec lequel
l'union européenne vient de signer un
accord de libre échange
donc c'est totalement incohérent comme
position et je pense que bruxelles joue
avec le feu puisque tout le monde sait
que le royaume uni a maintenant un
gouvernement qui est très bien installés
qui a une forte majorité au parlement et
donc les rapports de force qui ont pu
exister sous l'ancien gouvernement de
madame mais ne sont plus en vigueur
donc ça veut dire quoi selon vous que
bruxelles n'est pas vraiment un
raisonnable
je ne pense pas que bruxelles soit
raisonnable non et je j'attire
l'attention de vos spectateurs sur le
fait que le même homme qui avait négocié
ou plutôt qui n'avait pas négocié
j'allais dire il allait il avait négocié
l'accord du président mais en fait en
réalité il a échoué
il a échoué parce que l'accord qu'il
avait négocié et auquel il est resté
attaché pendant toute l'année et toutes
les années 2016 2017 2018 et jusqu'en
2019 michel barnier disait à répétition
que son accord était le seul accord
possible et qu' il fallait absolument
que le royaume uni le ratifient sinon il
n'y aurait pas d'accord et bien il a été
obligé de revenir sur ses pas et de
négocier un nouvel accord
donc même dans ses propres termes michel
barnier qui est maintenant toujours en
poste
avec le nouveau mandat de négocier donc
le la prévert site la fin de la période
de transition
c'est un homme dont la carrière récentes
sur ce dossier est jalonné d'échecs et
d'échecs d'échec majeur et on il a en
face de lui
bien au contraire un gouvernement qui
vient de remporter on l'oubli à cause du
corona virus mais qui a remporté il ya
très peu de temps en décembre une
victoire écrasante aux élections est dit
et qui est donc en position de force
un parent à parois par rapport à
bruxelles monsieur leblanc
merci d'avoir été en direct avec nous je
rappelle que vous êtes universitaire
spécialisé en géopolitique merci merci